you don't see how great you are that you
really have no idea a rod is JLo's
number one fan and supporter that's
Jennifer Lopez giving fans an inside
look at her life on the road in her
latest youtube video where she opens up
about the challenges of touring while
she's had some unforgettable moments on
stage during her it's my party tour it
hasn't all been easy
[Music]
coming down my face during one show she
herself on the face with her microphone
started bleeding and had a mini meltdown
[Applause]
beyond the florists singer also played a
few shows with the flu that feels much
better today I don't have a fever
like I did the last two shows Jennifer's
fiancé Alex Rodriguez was there through
it all encouraging his wife to be every
step of the way it was Saturday night in
Vegas and you guys killed it and you
showed what you're a champion baby and
had the best show so far I'm so proud of
everyone but every time I see the show
they keep getting better and better and
better he really makes effort so do I
kind of be there for each other and it
means a lot to me JLo's 11 year old
daughter Emmy has also been by her
momma's side joining her on stage to
sing limitless
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
et was with JLo backstage after the
special mother-daughter moment in Los
Angeles where she couldn't help but rave
over her little ones talent she was just
like ready you know she just she has it
in her blood she has the Lionheart me
I'm just looking at her and I'm just
like you know hoping and praying it all
goes well and and she was like I got
choked up and she was fine she was
singing like a bird and I'm like